Assalamu
alaikum. I am Hashib from Afghanistan.
Can women study with men in same place?
I mean co-education.
As far as women studying in the same
university or same college as long as
the hijab is mentioned, there's no
problem. But if you are saying
co-education means they are studying in
the same class and sitting next to each
other, this is not correct in Islam.
Because in Islam there is hijab. So the
best thing for education is that if they
are very young maybe in the nursery or
junior kg or senior kg or first standard
or second standard till the woman and
boy becomes adult. If below the age of 8
if they sit in the same class there is
no objection. But I personally prefer
that the segregation is much earlier.
Maybe nursery no problem, junior age no
problem. But once they reach first
standard, second standard they should be
segregated. But in Islamically till they
become mature, till they reach puberty
below the age of nine, there is no
problem they can intermingle. It's
permitted. But I prefer at early age.
But regarding adults, whether in in the
secondary school or whether in colleges,
can men and women be present in the same
class and can they be educated? It is
not permitted in the Sharia for the
intermingling of the male and female.
And now this I've given the talk I even
handled the question session that when
there was a survey done in UK that which
get better results the co schools or
single sex schools the survey said that
the results of the single sex schools
were far superior than schools which had
girls and boys together and the reason
was that many a times the students were
trying to impress the opposite sex
to pay attention on the studies. The
girl will try to you know impress the
boys in the class. The boys will start
and try and impress the girls in the
class. So the concentration level
normally is less in a co school as
compared to a single sex school. And
Islamically also hijab is there. Islam
doesn't agree in intermingling. If you
have intermingling of successes and
co-education besides the level of
education coming down even Islam doesn't
permit it because there is segregation.
And the hijab is there and it should be
maintained besides the dress. Even
intermingling should be prevented and
Islam doesn't permit it. Hope that
answers the question.